each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
hmm no it's a few
welcome to my talk feel free to
interrupt me whenever we have questions
so my name is linda's galanis and i've
been working with David De Witt in the
database group and the University of
Wisconsin and I'm going to talk to you
today about focus of my thesis locating
data sources in large distributed
systems first let me try to motivate my
work by looking at the web bed it is
today so you have two parts to it
there's the surface web which is the
part that's accessible to web search
engines and is being crawled constantly
by search engines and you can cool it
very efficiently using google for
example and then there's the second part
of the web which is can y'all hear me by
the way okay good and the second part of
the web is some people called the hidden
web or the Deep Web and this is the part
that's inaccessible to search engines
and resides usually in database backends
and behind some servers and some studies
have estimated this part to be four
hundred to five hundred fifty times
larger than the surface web and you can
actually you can't actually query this
part of of using google for example so i
want to query this data and there's two
ways to do it one is to download the
entire thing to a central place and you
know run queries against it and the
problems with that approach is that it
might be not scalable and it might be
not possible because the Deep Web maybe
not may not be able to be downloaded and
the other approach is to push those the
queries to the data source of themselves
and in essence this means we have to do
this riveted query processing so there
are many challenges to doing that one of
them is security authentication
interface agreements and all this my
thesis is focused on the problem of
scalable data source locations in
distributed systems and this I think
this is a critical component for
building a disabled core processing
system in the Internet scale and it's
the first step before doing the civic to
optimization and distributed query
execution and I'm going to talk about
this problem and try to illustrate it so
what do you expect to find web data and
the hidden web in my thesis I assume
that I have a large number of
distributed independent and autonomous
data sources that look to the outside
world like XML repositories in the sense
that they store xml documents and export
some kind of xml query interface like
XPath for example and examples of such
data sources can be relational database
management systems today almost every
wonder is trying to put XML
functionality into their systems and
there are a lot of vendors also that
sell xml database systems that can serve
as database backends for the Deep Web
and then there can be xml documents on a
web server or even win a fast that's
supposedly going to be exported and a
big sporting an xml view to the outside
world so let me try to strip the problem
I have a large number of data sources in
the Deep Web new data sources become
available others change their data and I
want to encourage against all those data
sources one way is to build a data
center download the entire web and run
the users queries against this this data
center which is can be done or may not
be able to be you or you can you can do
it or you can do it depends on what the
data sources give us data the other way
the naive approach is in order to make
to ensure that you actually run your
question the entire data set you just
send your kid to every everybody but of
course this is not scalable what I would
ideally like to do is given a user's
query determine which data sources
have results for this query and send the
school only to those data sources and
this is the problem of locating data
sources in such a sibling systems now
before I go on I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about XML and xpath that I'm
going to be using throughout the talk so
this is an example XML document it's
supposed to hold data for library and
XML as well as you see in markup
elements and attributes that surround
the data in this case the catalog
element contains all the the books that
are available for checkout at the
library and the reservations element
contains all the books that have been
checked out by library patterns now this
is an XPath query this particular query
retrieves all the books that have been
offered by tannenbaum and are in the
catalog element of the library means all
the books that have not been checked out
and I written by tannenbaum what the
expert processor would do is it would
start matching the path with in a
document this in this way and for each
book that it retrieves it will match the
corresponding predicate down here and it
will return as a result for the query
the book that has been this is the
second book here now another interesting
XPath operator is the double slash here
oops and what this will do is it it will
return any book that is written has been
written by tannenbaum anywhere in the
document in this example it will return
this book also and another interesting
you and useful xpath operators just the
star operator which basically means any
tag in this query would not only return
books by written by ten bound but would
also return articles and whatever done
bump is written basically so I've talked
to you about the knave approach of
running queries on on the Deep Web nom
trying I'm going to present you with two
alternative designs for locating data
sources first one is the pier in this
approach and oh
presented in the conference of advanced
automation systems engineering in the
summer 2003 so and let me let me try to
provide a history of how this approach
was actually developed I was put in the
University of Wisconsin was part of the
Niagara project which is an Internet
scale query processor that runs xml
queries over over xml data it has
downloaded from the internet the
specific problem we had in this system
was that we had a large number of
documents and we wanted to run an XPath
query against the entire collection of
documents and of course running the this
specific expert for each document is not
you know effective so you need some kind
of an index and in the Nagra system we
used an xml search engine which is
basically an inverted index that maps
XML elements and text keywords to
documents with some structural
information so for example for this
query book author equals ton bound that
the reviews of the books written by ten
bomb the search engine would process the
inverted lists from the search engine
doing using some operator and we would
determine which documents would have
results for this specific way and the
rest of the documents we don't process
at all so when I started my thesis I
extended this approach to to a
distributed case and introduced the pier
index which is basically a list which
maps element names and attribute names
to a list of laws that have those
attributes and element names in their
data so for this specific query each
node I maintains appear index and for
this specific query what would what will
happen is that first we take the book
the book node list and we find which
nodes have booked in their data then we
intersect with the offer a node list and
now down further and then with a tun
abang key
no list and find out that notes four and
five have only have the relevant data to
this query now the question is how do we
build those appearances the I wanted to
have a system that was consisting of
independent autonomous data sources
running Niagara servers so one one way
to build that the system is through
huddle ad-hoc network formation so what
happens in this case is a node contact
some other node and they built neighbor
relationships and so on and when you
have a query and that the specific node
if you don't do anything else you have
to flood your query to all your
neighbors in order to get all the
results that are there in the network
and of course this does not scale well
you see how how bad it is so instead of
just joining and becoming neighbors
notes exchange data that allows them to
build this small peer index and this way
when you have a query at a node you
consult your peer index and you can
immediately send the query to notes that
will have results for your query now
I'll take you through an example of how
this is actually done in the system
suppose that we have two nodes one of
them is an optionally note that auctions
of paintings with prices in here and the
other one is an artwork girl gallery
that sells sculptures now for some
reason those two notes want to come
together and cooperate so what will
happen is that node one will send note
to some its metadata tags element and
attribute names and some interesting
keywords and the same thing will be done
by note 2 and this way the notes will
build this peer index as you see here so
this allows node want to know that
sculptures are present or node two now
when a third note comes along
suppose that we have a knock tioning no
optioning said that options of
sculptures this node will also contact
one of the other nodes no 2 in this
example and we'll give it its tags and
it's interesting keywords and no two
will forward this message to node 1 and
will reply to note 3 with the
information that's already in the
network and in this way nodes a comment
there / index and know about each
other's data so whenever you submit I
could it to any node for example
according to note to this quarry this
particular query retrieves all the open
options that involve paintings no two
will consult its peer index and will
rule out note 3 as a candidate for
receiving the square now we can imagine
when nodes become part of the system
those lists grow linearly and we
introduce horizons as a way to bound
them let me explain to you what horizons
do in this case for example at node 1
here has a horizon that has that is that
it's who's size is a one hop in the
network which means that no not one
knows only about note 2 and does not
know about note 3 not knowing about note
3 means that not one does not store any
information about note 3 in its peer
index and this in this case a query
originating at node one that needs data
from mode 3 will be first sent to know
to be using the pier index and then note
2 will forward the query to know three
so what I'm trying to illustrate here is
that you if you you can bound you're in
front the information in the pier and
this is in order to burn their size but
there's trade-offs and in the message in
the number of messages you need to get
to the actual data sources so for
example yeah
right so semantics can be built as a
layer on top of of this I'm not I'm not
I'm assuming that the nodes have have an
agreement of what they are actually
talking about in their data so if you
want to build some unless you may you
may have to introduce themes you may
have to introduce a collection of things
that mean price for example and build
that as a layer on top of the system
maybe you could do something
automatically but most of the times I
mean some of the times you won't be able
to do anything automatically gift to
actually look at the data itself to see
if a specific tag means the same thing
in all data sources but I'm not doing
this in my research what what is in
which one mm-hmm so in this horizons
note 2 is forwarding 21 knowledge about
the keyboard itself and it's masking and
knowledge about entry is not stored in
the and the pier index of note 1 but the
fact that there's a keyword sculpture on
on entry is reflected on n one here
which oh no the fact the fact that we
see here so n 3 has sculptures but and
in the full index case you can see it
here but in the horizon case you use and
two things that sculptures are only
present on n 2 and n once things at on
the sculptures are the only present in
two and so the general idea is that when
you have a horizon and you have some
notes within the horizon and then you
have some notes on the boundary of the
horizon and some notes outside when you
have a career issue that node 1 and the
data is on the nodes that you see marked
here not one we think for example that
no date the data on no date is a recital
node 7 and the same thing for node 4 and
will forward the query to note the notes
on the boundary and I could and then the
notes of the boundary will forward the
query to the nodes outside the horizon
which will incur extra messaging and
finally the the nodes will respond with
curlers career results so how else are
we bound of bounding the pier index
information and there's another way of
bonding the number of keywords but I'm
not going to talk about
you can ask me offline about that it's a
kind of a technical detail so I've built
the system and run experiments on it
I've built a network of XML search
engines that have those parentheses and
there that also have the inverted
indexes that do structural queries on
xml documents and I've built it using
Java and brevity bean and I took data
from ebay about forty five gigabytes and
ended up with four hundred fifty five
megabytes four hundred fifty megabytes
of data and about 400 megabytes of
inverted index on each node and about 8
kilobytes of peer index that and each
node was serving about 60,000 70,000
documents and each document essentially
describes an auction of a specific item
and I run experiments on our
departmental Clark cluster and each node
had about 12 users each of them
submitting XML queries xml search who is
requesting items for on in a specific
category and their nodes joined and
formed the network network the Ted 9 hop
diameter and an average of three
neighbors per node and there were many
many nodes with few neighbors and very
few notes with very many neighbors which
is typical of peer-to-peer networks and
this are some of the results I got so
this graph shows you the query
throughput in the system in chorus per
minute on the x axis you have flooding
on the left which basically means no
peer index at all and full information
on the right which means in the pier
index that everybody knows about
everybody in the system in the hundred
node network and then in the middle you
have horizons of varying sizes and as
you can see full information has very
good the best performance and the
performance degrades as you as you limit
the information that the three sites in
the pier index and flooding is really
really bad so the lessons from this
experiments is that
can get up to 20 times faster throughput
better throughput using just an 8k peer
index / note which is very important and
flooding is surprisingly bad we didn't
expect flooding to be that bad and just
hundred nodes and what we can say that
knowledge of where your data is is very
crucial in doing distributed query
processing in such environments and
there's a clear trade-off between the
size of the pier index and the
performance of query processing yeah
it's independent derive for each node it
ended its horizon right and in their
experiments the horizons is measured in
terms of hops network ops are oft in
terms of radius maximum network ops for
two other nodes beyond which there is no
data recording the pier index of the
specific node
well in this in this experience all the
notes had all the keys that were in the
in the data in all nodes so the horizon
just limited the number the node IDs
that were stored in the pier index I'm
not sure if you're asking this
oh right in the disk from but you know
if you had the larger network you
potentially you would use the silence
can be distributed this renovation is
going to be disabled okay
yep
right right right well in the in our
experiments with the real system we
could only go up 200 notes 200 notes so
full information was just 8 k so I would
stay here if I would want to build this
the next one is like 7.5 k which is not
measurable but it's not an interesting
difference but it shows how the
performance of various when we won you
when you are forced to take more hops to
get to your data yeah right right
so the data from ebay had has has
basically the same schema in my
experiment so I took the data and put
some XML tags that actually say what
would which thing is a price which thing
is a description and the heterogeneity
was in the categories each item was will
belong to so it's it's server in the
experiments was a scientist spectrum of
categories that it was serving up so
this was how the data was used questions
on this part ok so now I'm going to talk
about distribute catalogs which was
presented in a very large databases
conference in the summer 2003 and before
starting out you know tried to to
contrast it to the previous approach in
the pier in this approach we had a trade
war trade-off in the size of the P and X
versus the number of network messages
that were used we were actually incurred
during query processing and there was
uncontrolled application across notes me
meaning that each note was managing its
own view of the network and another rock
formation was not that good because you
it's you you require in order of N
squared Network messages to build a
network of n nodes with full information
on the pier indices which is not bad if
if you if you see the query performance
but and it since it's one a one-time
costs it's not bad either but in the
disability catalyst always want to
follow one to follow different design
approach so we partitioned the pier
index across nodes and this this way the
number of network messages is
independent of the pier in success so
I'll show you why this is and we use
controller application for load
balancing since the pier index is
partitioned and we use we try to make
network formation more scalable by
leveraging BHD technology and that talk
to you about that as we go on so the
concept of the catalog what's what's
what's the what's a catalog framework
going to do it for you you have a large
number of data source again and each
data source what it does is if
process its data and creates some cattle
of information in the case of XML the
catalog information contains elements
and for each element and attribute in
the data it creates a summer information
that's not specific so and the schedule
of information is fed into the catalog
service the catalog service for now is a
concept that when given a query it will
take its elements attributes and
predicates and it will give you then the
know the data sources that you actually
have to visit in order to get results
for the query the rest of the data
sources you don't need to bother at all
with a square and in this part of the
work I propose building the catalog
servers using distribute hash table
technology so what are the civet hash
tables so they're basically hash tables
that have this interface that allows you
to die allows you to put an object using
its key and to get it back using its key
and specifically those hash tables are
implemented as a peer-to-peer network as
a structured overlay Network in that
neighbors choose specific neighbors
specific nodes as neighbors and each
peer in this network is responsible for
a specific key range which is dynamic
and put them get gets routed to the
appropriate node so example disabled
hash tables are you khon kaen cord and
pastry and they're more than many more
there's been a lot of research in this
field and they have very desirable
properties so they're very scalable and
they require an order of log and
messengers for put and get in an end
node network and the surgeon butwith
goes linearly with a number of loads
that join the system and nodes can join
and leave dynamically and that
please take care of maintaining those
good properties and n nodes can contact
any node in the network that's already
in the network and join so this impetus
tips are good thing there there's been a
lot of research and I expect them to get
better over time so how can I use those
distributed hash tables to build the
catalog service for locating data
sources the first thing I have to do is
define the keys and the objects after a
lot of thought the keys the the design
we came up with is the keys are XML
elements and attribute names and the
objects that are stored in the DHT our
node ID and some repairs and summary
contains all the paths leading to the
Associated element with the summary and
an optional value some and I'll go into
an example to show you how this is
actually built so let me start the
example by considering a data source
that's a library and this again has a
catalog element that contains all the
books that have not been checked out the
reservations element that contains a
book in checked out and some membership
elements that have some prices
associated with its membership so what
are the keys I derive from this data set
in this case it's all the elements and
attribute names in in my data so and the
objects are built as follows for book I
record all the paths in the data that
lead to book for author I do the same
thing I record all the parts of the data
that lead to offer but since author has
values I also include a value summary to
reflect those values and the value
summer can be any of your favorite value
summers like bloom filters histograms
ranges if its numerical values and I do
the same thing for price so what do I
fee to the DHT I've give it this the key
I create derived from the author tag
name and the object is the summary
tagged with a node ID now let's put in
some other data source in the example I
have three libraries three bookstores
and some other data sources have a
relevant data this example and let's
assume that book stores have data that
looks like this there's books and since
you can buy those books there's a price
associated with
and note here that price is below the
book element whereas price in the
leverage was below the membership
element so the summaries would look like
this there's only one path to offer so
book bookstore and one pastor price and
the corresponding value summers now the
DHD Maps keys to aunty identifier space
and let's assume that those keys keys
are maps as you see here in the in the
slide and similarly notes map to the
same identifier space and thus become
responsible for specific key range in
this case note one is responsible for
storing title of information about
author and book ISBN and note 3 4 title
and price and of course these cue ranges
are dynamic so they changes more nodes
join the system and the BG takes care of
that and now I assume for simplicity at
all nodes have joined the vhd and are
about to upload the cattle of
information on to the catalog service
what will happen is a little show you
the example for for offer and price node
one will process its data and send
summary about offer to itself because
this is he the node one is the catalog
no responsible for offer catalog
information and it will send price
summary the price summary to node 4
which is responsible price information
and it will tag each summer with its
node ID question and no two will do the
same it will process its data and upload
the cattle of information to the
corresponding nodes and guided by the
DHD of course and note 3 will do also
the same thing now from the viewpoint of
the catalog service so how does the
catalog information how is the catalog
information stored on a node so node 1
is responsible for those two tags in the
data and it will store it into it will
receive summer that look like this so
and it will store the data in a b-tree
and the key is derived from from the
summary as yes you see here and this is
basically the inverse
in the data that's why the key of the
bee tree is the inverse path in the data
and each kick in maps to the
corresponding node IDs and the value
summaries for this specific element so
now if a couple of services it receives
a query I quit an xpath quarry to
resolve like this one books or book
author equals 10 bomb if there are no
special operands like double slasher
star just the simple key lookup will
retrieve all the value summers that we
need to end will tell us which nodes we
need to send a specific query tool if
the court looks like this they're
basically there's a double slash up
front you start a range scan using the
lower bound key author book and then you
check all the value summers and of this
bit of the nodes i beez you find along
the way if the code is more complex you
have double slashing in two places of
the query you start the range gun using
the author key and for each key that you
retrieve you check that it has a
reservations element in it and then you
check the corresponding value summers so
two examples to show you how this works
the first query retrieves all the books
off of background bomb and let's assume
that it's submitted at node 3 now using
the target element of the path
expression offer the DHD takes us to
node 1 which is responsible for author
cattle of information and no one tells
us that nodes 1 through 6 have offering
their data then using the predicate
offer equals 10 bomb let's assume that
we can further narrow down the number of
note that we need to send a query to to
note 2 and node 5 meaning that only
those two nodes appear have a talent
bombing their data so this is the answer
to note yeah they did
there are the author summers they
actually know their summers include the
summers are history in this case the
salmon can be a bloom filter that you
can give it this predicate and tells you
if data on a node has has time bomb on
it and of course it can give you false
positives not all the values of death
basically summarizing all the values
using some some of the common techniques
okay so basically probing probing the
value some are using this predicate it
can tell you that only node 2 and node 5
have have Tannenbaum in their data might
have right but it definitely can def it
can not give you a false negative so
basically the value some will further
now down the notes you have to visit so
and then the core is sent to just those
two notes for the more elaborate example
the now the disco he retrieves all the
prices for books offered by Tannenbaum
and there's two branches in this query
so we start to submit the query again on
03 and we use the target element of the
first branch and DHT takes us to node 4
which is responsible for price capital
of information and there the catalog
servers are not for tells us that node
to node three not four have only prices
below book in their data libraries have
also practicing their data but it's not
below book so they're not included in
this list then we use the second the
target element of the second branch and
we go to node 1 which is responsible for
offer catalog information and there we
use the ton bomb predicate and we find
that only know two needs to receive this
query and the answer goes to 0 3 which
submits the query to node 2 so a little
bit about how the system evolves
dynamically so there's as those notes
are already in the catalog service and
you note wants to join the catalog
servicing
can contact any any node in the system
and it finds its place in the identifier
ring and becomes immediately responsible
for the author cattle of information
which eventually we move to node 1 and
at the same time it injects to the
catalogue service it's it's own cattle
of information when I know leaves some
other node become responsible for for
the cattle of information so yeah if it
leaves gracefully it's it right right
well it's not going to be gigabytes of
data yeah but if it leaves gracefully
all this is ok you can transfer the data
say right otherwise you can use some of
the facilities in the present NADH this
and keep replicas of cattle of
information and revert to those if it
just dies so by using the catalog
service by using the DHT to build the
catalog servers this way there there are
certain scalability issues that arise
and i'll talk to you about those now and
they stem from the fact that there's
going to be non-uniform element access
during catalog lookups some of elements
are more popular than others and and
that's natural and this non-uniform
element access we'll need to note non
uniform load distribution of requests to
the catalog service and the solution is
adaptive key management basically what
you do is once you detect an overload do
you create new keys and distribute the
summer information and I'm going to talk
to you about two techniques splitting
and replication so splitting I'll talk
to you about this now you assume let's
assume that the node 0 is responsible
for cattle of information about price
and let us also assume that price can be
found in data that looks like this so
you have prices of cars price of bikes
prices of boats and so on right so you
can imagine that price is going to be a
very popular
element and it's going to be looked up
very often so they request straight on
node 0 may become prohibitively large so
node 0 will initiate a split what it
will do is it will take the the summer
information for price and split it this
way by creating for new keys by grabbing
the parent element of price and those
phone your keys will be assigned to four
new nodes by the DHT at the same time
each node maintains a meta key map which
records basically the split that has
taken place so node 0 puts this entry up
here in its medica map and next time
some other node asks for price catalog
information it will also get as a
response this entry and subsequent
subsequently it will based on the query
use the alternative keys to to request
catalog information and this way the
load is distributed across the altar of
5 nodes so the red part of the load
corresponds to queries that end in
double slash price which are still
handled by this node 0 and the rest of
the load goes to the four new nodes and
this is this approach is called split
replicate and because the information
that because not 0 still maintains the
information that it's also present or
not 104 if we don't want to maintain
duplicate information we just throw it
away and then the load for queries the
ending in double slash price will also
be transferred to those four new nodes
and this is called splitters and it has
a disadvantage that who is that and in
double slash price will have to go to
all four new nodes to get full catalog
of information and so incurring more
network messages so and you'll see how
this affects performance replication is
simple again request rate increases and
no to request a number of new keys in
this case two new keys to widget at maps
price and low
two new keys correspond to two new nodes
and the meta keep my pantry looks like
this and subsequently when notes receive
the century they will do a round robin a
request on those three keys and the load
will be distributed evenly approximately
across the nodes so so how is splitting
compared to application so splitting
adapts faster because it uses the
structural information in the data and
it's better during updates because you
need to only update at most two replicas
of course it's specialized because it
needs hierarchal data to work and it's
not effective in marginal cases where
the hierarchy is not is not deep enough
for example but in marginal cases you
can always revert to replication which
is more general it's always applicable
but it requires more messages during
updates and it doesn't use special
information if it's if you have it so
suppose some performance experiments I
used real-world schemas from ww XML dot
org that registers xml schemas have
actually companies use with their xml
data and the iphone's 30 schemers of
varying domains banking arts
transportation music and all of them had
about 3,500 unique tags and some many
tags in common and although steamers
have about 16,000 unique paths from root
to the leaves so and I generate a large
pool of about a million queries from
this data containing both double slash
and star in the queries and they took
the cold simulator and the put catalog
query processing layer on top of it and
did some detailed time simulations for
catalog requests so it was a two-phase
experiment the first I implemented the
catalog stretches and run the query
workloads against them to to to take
measurements for single site operations
and then I plug these numbers into the
simulator and simulated five different
networks and
so in this case that there's no actually
there is my metadata there's no data I
can't get the data but i can create i
can still create catalog information
using the metadata and some
distributions for the data the catalog
does not store data i'm not interesting
installed a that the catalogs those
metadata so users and experiments a bit
xpath queries and we had about 10 users
per node and i tested four different
strategies one with no load balancing
the requests one using split replicate
split toss and replication which created
one replica at a time when there was an
overload and the the load balancing
action was triggered basically using a
threshold on the catalog requests in the
system so the first results this show
you the response they average response
time of catalog queries in the system
the best performers is split replicate
and followed by your application which
does worse in the more demanding
networks because it doesn't it does not
adopt as fast split those does yeah
uh
no I say I expect the centralized
database to perform faster if if if if I
can scale it as ilysm as much as I want
this I'm trying to see how what I need
to do to build a a peer-to-peer system
that implements as catalog service a
centralized database a different design
well this figures contain network
delaying them so centralized database if
I can scale it infinitely is definitely
going to be better right but I mean I
don't have specific you know I don't
have a specific amount of service i can
use i can I don't I can't through you
constraint that so I'm just looking at
the distributed system itself so as I
was saying split toss is performs really
bad because of course that look like
this well we have a double slash at the
end of the path expression since they
generate on the average much many more
messages than the other lookups and cord
of course performs worse the just no
load balanced performs worse and it's
even and it would perform even worse if
it weren't allowed to drop some requests
which you don't see here so the second
set of is the second graph shows you the
throughput of queries achieved in the
system again on the x axis has the
varying network sizes and the y axis
gives you the throughput again split
replicate maintains the best scalability
characteristic in throughput case and
splitters and replication do also as
well and no load balancing does not give
you a scalable throughput yeah yeah
so the workload I I take all this all
this element that I find in low schemas
and they I assign them I create queries
based on some probability that they will
let those that an element will appear in
a query and I tried different workloads
where the LMS of the further down in the
hierarchy are more likely to produce
queries and where there's a uniform
distribution of course among the
elements and all of them gave me similar
similar graphs or I need to mention
though that if you don't have a double
slash in your and your queries then
split toss and split replicate the world
event is essentially performed the same
because you don't they won't incur extra
messages but double slash enquiries is a
very common feature in XPath for it so
there there there there with some
probability I don't have yeah yeah yeah
no my system handles the part of it that
needs that it needs to actually find the
data sources so if you have some some
fancy operation on an XPath branch it
will just take the branch intelligent
and will tell you you can find data and
those data sources and then you can send
the query over then it will do this fan
separation on the data source or say not
on the catalog so if you if you
computing an average or a minimum you
will get the data sources that you have
to visit in order to retrieve all the
data to compute the minimum
well I'm i think that solving the
problem of locating the data source is
the first step to doing everything else
and by knowing where it is then you can
build scalable more scalable strategies
to around your current I'll have some
slides on that later on my third part of
this and you'll see an example of that
Yeah right
so the bottleneck the bottleneck in this
experiments is the request straight on
an individual nodes note that we receive
a large number of requests get get
clogged and they can't they bring down
the throughput of the whole system so
there's some popular elements that are
looked up frequently so if you don't do
load balancing then this becomes the
bottling the processing of the catalog
request becomes the bottleneck it's a
CPU year I know it is the CPU because
catalogue information is very small and
fits in the CPU i'll show you the sizes
fits in main memory then i'll show you
the sizes and on our latest life so it's
not it's the proper the processing time
for catalog requests of course as you
can see here the response time increases
and this some of these increases due to
network aids because when you go from
500 to 5000 nodes you need more hops to
access the actual catalog mode when you
issue your cuddle awkward because
there's this log n factor in the DHD so
this slide is kind of explaining the
previous ones on the x axis you have
nodes ranked by the number of the
requests they receive and in this case
you just have with the only the 51st of
the 5000 nodes and on the y-axis you
have the number of requests each node
receives so with no load balancing
there's a there's a lot a few note that
received very many requests and become
the bottleneck of the system when you
when you when you enforce load balancing
split replicate and replication even out
the curve as you see here and split dose
also even saw the curve but it generates
more measures and that's why you see the
gap to relative to R and s are here so a
little about the catalog sizes the
average catalog size in our experiments
was about 12 to 15 kilobytes on each
node and the load balancing techniques
increases the average catalog size by
about two kilobyte
which is nothing another important
factor here is the matter came up size
in the split split replication case it's
35 kilobytes for each node because it's
not maintains essentially the same
matter came up and about six kilo bytes
in the replication cases and it's more
in the splitter replicate case because
there's a recursive splits and you need
to keep her around more information when
you split based on data another
interesting metric is the yeah question
yeah
right in this specific experiments
there's only 30 schemas but in the real
world you may have 30,000 streamers the
actual number of the actual number of
what yeah well I could only get 30
schemas that that's that's the that was
the reality but I expect to be more than
30 schemas around there I expect
expected to scale because the cattle of
information is going to be distributed
across all nodes so for this experiment
is just 15 kilobytes what if what if it
is a megabyte it's not big information I
get so it's not a big amount of
information because the cattle of
information itself is distributed across
all nodes and once you add notes the
system scales automatically because you
get a distribution of the cutter of
information yeah so then the maximum
catalogues is also an interesting
measure because this is the worst case
notes are expecting I've going to be
expecting so in the 5,000 no network the
maximum catalog size was bulk a megabyte
for further specific experiments and the
general it's not expected to be very
large so some related work yeah I'll
skip that in the interest of time in I
can talk to you about that like to talk
about some other work I've done so this
is the third part of my thesis in schoo
goes back to your question doing the
tribute aggregation in a peer-to-peer
system so i'll explain i'll show you two
slides I'll explain the problem and very
briefly and show you what what we
actually achieved so imagine that you
have the catalog service and it allows
all the data sources to discover each
other and you have some buyers in this
network that want to buy a specific
digital camera and find the retailer
with a minimum price so what you do here
you see an complex xpath expression that
computes the minimum of the press of a
specific model and the returns the URL
of the retailer that has this
specifically that has this price so what
you can imagine is that the catalog
system will find the retailers for you
but each buyer will have will in turn
query each retailer to get the price and
compute the minimum and what will what
you have is this mess here and the
number of measures is going to if the
buyers and the retailers grow linearly
the number of messages is going to grow
quadratically so what we propose is use
an aggregation layer and assign appear
in the network the maintaining of this
minimum this specific minimum of four
the specific digital camera model and
then buyers would just hurry the
specific pier and retailers will update
their pride when whenever they update
their price they'll inform this
aggregation maintainer about the new
results and I tried to evaluate this
scheme using a distributed commodity
trading scenario and I built a simulator
that simulates the civet commodity
trading between traders and this
particular case you see the test results
of from 100,000 node network with
hundred thousand node traders and
varying number of commodities using the
and then the x-axis and the system with
the aggregation layer constantly
outperforms the system with without the
aggregation layer and if there are none
large number of traders / commodity as
in the in this case where over there
only a small number of commodities the
system without the application layer
does not work so you need even if you
have the catalog servers you need to do
more if you want to execute the more
complex queries in a scalable fashion
and I've recently built the system using
pastry and DB XML and i'm currently
running experiments on the cluster again
using
similar scenario and some other work
I've was involved with is as a part of
the Niagara project an address is an
Internet query system that works on XML
data and they've worked on the query
engine and the cleanser prototype of of
the system I also did some theoretical
work on defining the xml query algebra
that we used in our system and or using
now and they also worked on the inverted
list engine of of the Niagara system so
to conclude I've presented you the
problem of locating data sources and
I've presented two solutions to tackle
it I think it's an important problem in
a growing internet and it's the first
step in doing internet scale distributed
query processing and civic or
optimization for doing the civic
organization you need to figure out how
to maintain statistics over again and
how to make service exchange those
statistics in order to form to make
declaratively the declarative queries
work at the civet environment this will
this research I see there's a part of
the feel of data centric distributed
systems and there's been a lot of talk
about the internet becoming data sending
and to find about finding ways of making
it data-centric as opposed to host
centric as it is now so and I guess
that's it if you have any questions
right
so I haven't looked at trust in this
environment but what but I think data
sources that want to receive queries are
willing to share with the rest of the
world some summary that will make
queries go to their site and eventually
generate revenue for them so it's not a
scheme where you give out your data you
just give out the schemas you're using
and some summary of how your data looks
like mm-hmm
right
so somebody might report a lower price
for example then they actually have yeah
yeah that's gonna be an issue that I
mean I don't have a solution to that in
this particular research yeah
in princess right right right so Google
needs to a specific thing needs to talk
to compute the page rank and in order to
compute the page rank there's no there's
no clear way to do it in a distributed
fashion and Google does not does not
care whether it has the most up-to-date
information so in this in this scenario
I assume that data sources will want to
receive queries and since Google cannot
keep the most up-to-date prices for
example then data sources are not
guaranteed to to get close to Google
they want to receive the quiz directly
so I query will the catalog service will
point to those to the data sources it
will answer the porridge update this is
one thing that this scheme makes better
than google for example yeah yeah
actually yeah actually my my office mate
has recently published a paper actually
it's not published yet as a has a paper
that does distributed pagerank
calculations using a similar schemes so
but in a simple fashion I don't think
you could do it as efficiently as Google
desert the full-text indexing in this
fashion
mm-hmm
right in this in this in this design
there's no mm-hmm right you can't write
you have to distribute it you have to
essentially distributing your entire
index but this is not what I'm trying to
do here right but you can actually do it
and you can we have a system at the
Wisconsin again at the distributes then
the keyword index across notes the
actual index that Google has and in my
ultimate as part of his thesis work has
written some book like page rank on top
of it so there is a distributed indexing
system that that's what Google does in
the Civil it fashion but I guess it's
not going doing this as a scalable as
booming that but essentially Google is a
distributed system itself it has a large
number of data center is doing the same
thing so any other questions